bonsoir nicolas conquet merci d'être
avec nous donald trump qui annonce donc
le lancement de son propre réseau social
pour dit il résister face à la tyrannie
des géants des technologies c'est un
projet très très ambitieux
ma fille est assurément on peut on
pouvait pas attendre au moins de sa de
trump là il ya un vrai projet avec des
grosses ambitions qui vont pouvoir être
lancées à l'horizon 2022 c'est pas
anodin ça arrive lors d'une année
charnière une année d'élection et on
peut vraiment compter à ce que ça puisse
permettre à 32 remobiliser un toute sa
base et deux portes et un peu au devant
de la scène et sans qu'une seule
quelques heures sans shadowbane toutes
ces technologies toutes ces techniques
qui sont pratiqués par les géants de la
silicon valley pour passer a couvert les
voix des conservateurs de permettre à
donald trump et au candidat républicain
de porter à au plus grand nombre leur
voix et leurs promesses de campagne donc
effectivement on l'avait dit une manière
de revenir et de clairement peser
politiquement ont lancé un précédent
alors ça a été un secret pour personne
dès qu'il a quitté la maison blanche il
avait à souhait et on pouvait compter
sur lui pour qu'il soit mobilisée et
qu'ils puissent continuer à cheval en
politique que ce soit de manière
politicienne ou métapolitique je pense
que ceux qui pensaient qu'il allait
profiter d'une retraite en jouant au
golf amara la gaule ont peut-être parlé
un peu trop rapidement et on voit que yo
là il ne manque pas de projets de
soutenir des candidats républicains et
de continuer à lancer cette dynamique
qui était initialement making it again
qui passe maintenant save america vu vu
la gestion déplorable de
l'administration actuelle
c'est faux la seule chose c'est ce qu'on
peut lire sur la page de garde
futur un réseau social ça veut dire en
gros que chacun aura sa vérité facebook
d'un côté donald trump de l'autre
alors c'est à dire que d'une part ces
réseaux sociaux se sont vraiment arrogé
un droit de dicter la fugue au temps de
faire les élections s'ils le voulaient
en modérant des différents contenus
profitant vraiment de niche de
traitement de faveur qui leur a été
attribué à savoir qu'ils n'étaient pas
tenus responsables ces propos alors
qu'il faisait de la modération il
passait donc deux plateformes à éditeurs
et de ska dans ce cas là ils devraient
être tenues redevables les responsables
des propos qui est qui publiaient sur
leurs plateformes maintenant l'idée
c'est surtout de pouvoir permettre à la
liberté d'expression et de ne pas passer
à couvert à plus forte raison un ancien
président de la république ainsi que tu
vois là toute la l'opinion de la moitié
du peuple américain
thomas bonneau nous disait vous l'avez
évoqué aussi ça fournira également un
service de vidéo à la demande et des
bosses tu casses non ok comment
pourrais-je et on chez les républicains
certaines
demandes dans une parmi les partisans
donald trump
alors c'est intéressant ce que cette
demande elle va bien au delà de la base
de 30 c'est vraiment le bon sens qui est
fait appel à cette décision à ce choix
de modifier un petit peu les catalogues
des programmations pas les nommer mais
de sega femme qui est vraiment cherche à
pousser un calendrier idéologique en
modérant les contenus et on va jusqu'à
supprimer des dessins animés des
classiques des veaux jeunesse des
aristochats ou que sais-je pour quelques
offense ou parce que les enfants
seraient est en mesure de saisir les
messages ou la portée de ses dessins
animés on a ça en passant tout à fait à
côté de l'aspect ludique entertainment
qui va être remis au coeur de cette
offre qui sera qui sera mise mise mise
au public le fait c est quand même
trempe le dit si bien il
s'inquiète donc jeu pour le traduire
tout ce qui vit par work tourner angers
de boudin pour rester polie et et le
voilà les elle est allée les sondages
les les participations le nombre de
membres de toutes les plateformes va en
diminuant parce que justement ils
souscrivent trop à cet agenda wac qui
est loin d'être du goût de tous les
abonnés de ces plateformes en mai
dernier à l'ancien président avait fait
son retour
de
mais ça n'a pas trop pris ça veut dire
aujourd'hui clairement qu'ils aient
besoin de de remobiliser ses partisans
donald trump ils sont aussi nombreux
qu'avant
aujourd'hui on est en train de parler
d'une affaire qui est pas loin d'avoir
signer les deux milliards de dollars
donc ça montre vraiment les ambitions et
que les investisseurs vont se ranger
derrière parce qu'ils croient dans le
pouvoir l'influencé le charisme et la
base du camp républicain qui sera prêt à
soutenir cette idée indépendamment de la
personne qui a derrière l'idée c'est ils
lui ont fait confiance non le courant
est monté il ya une dynamique derrière
on est à une année charnière comme je le
disais avec les élections de mid-term de
mi mandat qui auront lieu en 2022 et il
ya fort à croire que cette dynamique va
être bénéfique fructueuse et qu'elle
permettra d'avoir un vrai succès
électoral lors des prochaines élections
merci beaucoup à nicolas conc'air
d'avoir tu es avec mon porte parole
républicaine overseas france merci
d'être avec nous